dans ce quartier industriel de lits
vivent un atelier extérieur improvisé
comme il en est apparu un peu partout en
ukraine
une énorme quantité de bouteilles sont
entassés non loin d'une réserve de
produits combustibles et de quelques
bouts de tissus
tous les ingrédients pour assembler un
cocktail molotov
il vaut mieux faire ça à l'extérieur dit
vlad 18 ans depuis le début de la guerre
lui des membres d'une organisation
étudiante fabrique des armes
incendiaires artisanales et les expédie
offrons à carter et kiev
et sont destinés aux civils qui n'ont
pas d'armes pour se défendre explique
t-il vlad est devenu très habile au plus
fort de la demande son groupe et lui
pouvaient en produire 1500 par jour
depuis la demande a diminué mais ils
sont toujours prêts et en ont des
centaines en réserve son équipe cours
d'un aussi l'envoi de matériel
humanitaire
dans une guerre il y à la ligne de front
et la base arrière l'une ne peut pas
fonctionner sans l'autre explique-t-il
nous sommes prêts à aider de toutes les
façons possibles
si des gens ordinaires veulent faire
leur part de nombreuses entreprises de
l'ouest de l'ukraine et contribue aussi
à l'effort de guerre dans cet atelier de
couture les machines résonne 24 heures
sur 24 des travailleurs ici confection
du gilet pare-balles et des ceintures
pour équiper les soldats qui sont au
fond
il y à un mois d'attentes explique ce
responsable
nous ne prenons plus les commandes la
demande est trop forte
en pleine guerre difficile de
s'approvisionner en matières premières
nous avons assez de main à ces espaces
mais pas assez de tissus explique-t-il
ici des employés travaillent de longues
heures avec fierté
je ne peux pas tenir une arme dit oksana
mais je peux aider avec mon savoir faire
elle s'inquiète pour les militaires au
front
ça fait mal je ne suis pas une
magicienne mais j'aimerais arrêter cette
guerre dit elle d'ici là il faut
s'accrocher
[Musique]
travail travail travail jusqu'à la fin
près de six semaines après le début du
conflit ta détermination reste intacte
ici louis blouin radio canada iv